Suma's announcement is painful.
Certainly I wanted to be an idol, but I
think it's just a different thing. Yeah, I said there's
definitely a shoot today. I hope I
can meet Hiro-chan.  I
hope I can meet Hiro-chan already. From the side I have, Hiro-chan Kita
5 years old
[Music]
What's this
guy?  I forgot
that I had a big injury
[Music
] until I ate old trees
and did 5000 doctors
.
Sheath is really indebted to me 8 The person behind it is ad-san
Oh, that's right-thank you for your hard work, can you
rain?  Will you give me a garden
? Man
Army pattern From the
morning, the physique is too different.
0 Wait at the studio
Nozaki
After all, both of us are in a hurry and the day starts. Yes.